everyone John Roca for Collider I'm here
with two of the wonderful stars from
this new DreamWorks Animation film
abominable Tenzing Norgay trainer and
Albert's I I'm so happy to sit down with
you guys I just saw the movie last night
as I told Chloe just finished crying
this morning so it's a cool such a
fantastically sweet film Dez I wanna
start with you this character of Jett
what separated the experience from that
this project was like for you from other
projects you've been on uhm well it is
an animated film I've never done
anything like it and it was such a fun
experience it's very different because
we do have to read with the director
Jill we don't get to read with each
other all the time but we did get to do
it a couple times so but it was a lot of
fun and Jin is definitely a an
interesting character it was a lot of
fun to play you kind of look like him a
little bit yeah I get that a lot are you
worried about your sneakers as much yeah
yes I love sneakers so we were similar
in that would those are pretty badass I
have to say thank you how much of how
much of the work you did with bringing a
pen to life was from your own experience
but you knew somebody like this or
yourself or your love of sports or
traveling what did you bring the
enthusiasm did you find that within
yourself well thing is really just the
fun-loving like carefree really
energetic kids so I feel like I can
infuse some of my personality into him
we are similar in some ways but um
u.s. really it's kind of different to
for me in certain ways um yeah we've got
a lot in common yeah a lot of like the
scene with them the the blueberries that
was really fun for me to do kind of
infuse a lot of my personality there
he's kind of a foodie here and there's
yeah any success with basketball you're
both kind of travelers you've both
talked about traveling the world and
what have you did this film really
capture so incredibly the the power of
the beauty of China and did excite you
to me go and visit it more or experience
some of these things in firsts on these
sites
yeah that's scenery in the movie is
gorgeous you see so many beautiful
locations like the yellow mountain or
the Li Shan Buddha and
yeah it certainly made me want to go
back and visit more locations in China
I've already been to Shanghai before of
it yeah yeah I've never been to China
before but Jill always says that what
she wanted to do was show parts of China
that people maybe don't know about like
we all know the Great Wall and stuff
like that so it was really cool to see
the outside parts of China and I really
want to visit and the countryside yeah
yeah all the scenes in the countryside
with like the train or like the Gobi
Desert they're all just gorgeous yeah
the canola fields the canola fields is
fantastic right sequence right that's
one of my favorite scenes of the movie
yeah yeah and the core the the flying
clouds really incredible work one last
thing I want to ask you both as you look
at this film is there something that you
hope people take when they come out of
watching abominable it might separate
from other animated films well I think
the movie is just really about family
and how far you're willing to go for
family and whether it's the family
you're born with or the family you
create like with Yi Jin ping and Everest
yeah yeah I would put it that that's a
great way to put it it's also just to
learn to appreciate what you do have
around you because I feel like all the
characters kind of kind of selfish in a
way maybe not paying but we're all kind
of stuff you don't realise just like the
type of family that we have and the
support that and their really grow from
it they really go from the adventure
they go on Everest really kind of
teaches them a lot or shows them side to
them they may have not known before
also perseverance it's a big thing in
the movie um the koi fish just to not
give up and keep going when things get
hard
one last question do you both want to go
to ever steel is there any interest in
possibly climbing Everest at this point
in your lives
I know maybe okay maybe the base camp
great no we're not that is a Tenzing
Norgay trainer an outside from the new
film abominable I'm John Rogan from
Collider thanks for watching